president obama has called on vladimir
putin to withdraw support for these
pro-russian forces
he has been ignored
the kiev government threatened to use
force to drive them out of government
buildings they had seized in eastern
ukraine
but deadlines have come and gone while
ukrainian government forces have done
little but rattle their sabres in
military exercises
pro-russian forces in eastern ukraine
towns like slavyansk have shrugged off
kiev's threats
so the government has appealed to the un
to send peacekeepers
of forces immediately to support the
eastern regions in the struggle against
separatists
we are giving them a 24-hour deadline to
do this
we are all ukrainians and we have to
stick together
but our government is holding us back
we've had enough violence something
needs to be done urgently we don't want
the same situations in the east
president putin has denied any russian
involvement in these uprisings
the european union has expanded
sanctions against his inner circle and
threatened to tighten the noose on
russia's economy
but so far russia's president has shown
again that he believes that maintaining
the kremlin's dominance over its
neighbor makes the beastings of his
critics bearable